>> Jeff: JAMES TOOK A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT APPROACH.
A HIGH ARCING MISS.
NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE.
HE GETS A GREAT BOUNCE AND IF HE
COULD HAVE GOTTEN IT CLEANLY, HE
WOULD HAVE HAD A LOOK.
>> Mark: I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU
SAID.
DWIGHT HOWARD, DeANDRE JORDAN
INTO THE BALL GAME FOR
REBOUNDING PURPOSES, BUT IT
WORKED OUT FOR THE LAKERS.
RAN OUT OF TIME.
HOW ABOUT THE HUSTLE BY STEVE
KERR, GETTING OUT OF THE WAY.
>> Mike: JAMES UNABLE TO HIT THE
THREE FREE THROWS.
PORTER DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
TIPPING IT AWAY FROM THE BASKET.
AND STEPH CURRY AND THE WARRIORS
SURVIVE.
MEANWHILE, KLAY THOMPSON IN HIS
14th GAME BACK WITH AN ABSOLUTE
GEM.
33 POINTS, HE'S WITH LISA.
>> Lisa: I ASKED YOU HOW YOU
FEEL, YOU SAID, I FEEL GREAT.
JUST WHAT GOT INTO YOU.
WHAT GOT INTO YOU IN THAT FOURTH
QUARTER?
>> OH, MAN, I DON'T KNOW, LISA.
THAT WAS FUN.
AND -- I SAW A COUPLE GO DOWN
AND, YOU KNOW, NO MATTER HOW
MANY I MISS, I'M ALWAYS GOING TO
FEEL CONFIDENT I'M GOING TO MAKE
THE NEXT ONE.
>> Lisa: WHAT DID IT FEEL LIKE
FOR YOU TO GET THAT HOT AGAIN?
>> OH, MAN, IT'S -- IT'S
EVERYTHING, YOU KNOW?
I MEAN -- LAST TWO SEASONS WERE
WEIRD.
I'M NOT GOOD AT WATCHING AND
IT'S INSPIRING, HONESTLY, TO
KEEP GOING, KEEP WORKING,
BECAUSE I'M STILL NOT EVEN
PLAYER STARTER MINUTES.
>> Lisa: 14th GAME BACK, AFTER
MISSING 2 1/2 YEARS.
WHAT WAS THE WAIT LIKE, U.S. TO
GET BACK TO WHERE WE'RE USED TO
SEEING YOU?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, IT WAS
HARD.
IT WAS A LOT OF HARD DAYS.
A LOT OF DAYS ON THE SHUTTLE
BOARD, A LOT OF DAYS IN THE
SQUAT RACK, BUT MAKES IT WORTH
IT.
OUR FANS ARE INCREDIBLE, I
MEAN -- YOU SAW THE LAST THREE
FREE THROWS, THEY'RE LOUD, YOU
CAN'T HEAR NOBODY AND MAN, IT'S
JUST -- IT FELT AMAZING.
>> Lisa: WE MISSED YOU, TOO.
WELCOME BACK.
MIKE?
>> Mike: WELL, THE JOY THAT THE
GAME GIVES HIM IS EVIDENT EVERY
TIME HE PLAYS.
A LITTLE EXTRA SPECIAL, AFTER
WHAT HE WENT THROUGH IN THOSE
2 1/2 YEARS, THOSE TWO
DEVASTATING INJURIES.
AND A MAGNIFICENT PERFORMANCE
TONIGHT FOR KLAY THOMPSON.
NBA SUNDAY SHOWCASE TOMORROW,
PRESENTED BY REESE'S ON ABC, THE